Mary here with a gang spot news updates
the International for has concluded and
newbie has secured the five million
dollar prize over vici gaming after
valve started the prize pool at 1.6
million fans were able to add to the
bucket by purchasing the compendium
raising the total prize pool to 10
million nine hundred and thirty one
thousand one hundred and five dollars
forty-six percent of the total pool goes
to the first place winner newbie netting
them five million twenty eight thousand
three hundred and eight dollars for the
five-man team runner-up vici gaming took
home 13.5 percent of the prize pool
getting them 1 million four hundred and
seventy five thousand six hundred and
ninety nine dollars not bad just to give
you some perspective on this this is
more than the first place team took home
last year both teams are from China and
play a more aggressive style nudy is a
relatively new team to the scene only a
little over a year old assembled from
elite players newbie was close to being
eliminated in phase 2 and were required
to play a tiebreaker match to stay in
the tournament in the main event they
play vici gaming in the first round of
the upper bracket winning two to one
they continued on to a rematch in the
finals and after losing the first game
came back to win three two one our
friends at on gamers calm will have more
in-depth coverage of newbies victory at
ti4 and for more gaming news stay tuned
to gamespot com